now with a fresh wave of strikes
underway on the railways today new data
shows that the impact industrial action
is having on the economy pretty
significant the number of working days
lost to strike action hit the highest
level for a decade in October our
economics and data editor Ed Conway is
here
um Ed we've been sharing a calendar on
Sky News for the past few weeks of just
how packed December is when it comes to
strike action it feels like there's
something pretty much every day until
the new year what kind of pressure is
that putting on the economy then well
let me show you and it's worth saying
you know there's been so much talk from
from both sides for the government from
those privates from this public sets of
unions as well but you've really got to
go dig down into the data to get a kind
of clear sense of what's going on and
one of those pieces of data you're right
was was just updated this is kind of the
states of just how many days we're
losing to to strikes this is backward
looking it's worth just saying that and
you kind of get a sense of that by you
know looking at this period here that's
the 60s and the 70s when you he had
loads of days lost to strikes where we
are now it doesn't really look that high
does it so the data just from June to
October because some of the data wasn't
collected over covert so then you just
started collecting it uh recollecting
recently but even in that short period
over a million days lost to Industrial
action that though is still kind of well
below where you're you know 2011 which
of course was a really uh big year for
for strikes that was during the kind of
austerity period but worth noting that
that's before a lot of the extra strikes
that we're talking about now are due to
happen so in December you could see that
line kind of going up really quite High
uh indeed but another way of kind of
looking at this is looking at the number
of stoppages so this is just kind of an
arithmetic total of how many stoppages
there are across the economy at any
given time and actually already in this
period that like I say it's backward
backwards looking we're not talking
about this Christmas we're talking about
right uh what we had in previous months
it's already up to the highest level
that we've seen since 1988 so it's
already getting there and that Line's
going up but you know it's nothing as it
can had to that period of that was the
kind of winter of discontent in that
whole period of the 60s and the 70s that
was pretty high so there are some
definite historical parallels but we're
kind of you know got a long way to
travel on that yeah and I mean the one
thing that's
consisted throughout history is people
are striking over conditions and pay and
one of the main arguments is that you
know in this cost of living crisis
um you know the private sector pay has
risen to help people public sector pay
not so much what's what are the factors
behind all of that I mean that's exactly
it and it's worth just kind of looking
at public sector and private sector pay
uh and what you can see here is these
two lines once private private sector
one's the public sector they've moved
and this is just the rate at which
they're increasing each year and you can
see they've moved in kind of lockstep
more or less with each other up to kind
of there's the pandemic there and then
you can see a big Divergence that's the
private sector by the way uh that the
red line uh and the the dark blue lines
public sector but the significant thing
is really what's happened recently that
Gap has opened up between them and as a
result you know this is a lot of what
people are talking about right now look
private sector wages going up really
high public sector quite weak in terms
of wage inflation but that's only part
of it you know part of the story is you
know what about the levels you know if
you take a look at the apps absolute
level of your pay are you getting more
in the public sector or more in the
private sector and this chart kind of
shows you that it's looking at the
levels so basically if the line is
somewhere here above in the kind of Blue
Area then you're talking about public
sector pay being more generous than
private sector pay but you've got to
adjust see you can't just take you know
the arithmetic totals and say that
that's that's entirely comparable if you
adjust for the fact that you've got
different types of workers you've got
different regions of the economy well
actually the line looks more like this
so on the basis of that line look where
we are at the moment public sector
workers are being paid less than their
private sector equivalents I should say
it's invariably it's more complicated
than that because that doesn't take into
account pensions but even so on some
measures it is looking like they are
doing worse so you can see why there is
that kind of fight at the moment and in
this cost of living crisis we keep
hearing the government particularly
talking about global factors so
internationally the strike action in
this country is it being replicated
elsewhere well I mean I mean short
answer yeah us because you know we're in
a period where you've got inflation
going up to these crazy levels not just
in the UK but elsewhere around the world
and when that happens in the same way
that did in the 70s the same way that in
the 60s invariably people want higher
pay and that's not necessarily
replicated in what they're being given
but one kind of way of getting a sense
of how the UK Compares across the world
I mean some of these numbers uh are
quite you know take a while to collect
so we won't have the equivalent of the
one that I showed you a moment ago that
working days lost for a little bit but
in the meantime you can look at the
percentage of people who are members of
trade unions and here in the UK this is
comparing it's all around the world so
Denmark there at the top and you can see
the UK there somewhere in the middle but
actually interestingly slightly above
the oecd average but obviously we all
know that that's down a lot from where
it was back in you know the 70s and the
60s I'll show you actually this was
where it was in the 60s one interesting
thing though SJ look at this so the UK
is there okay so actually relatively low
and only a little bit above the oecd
average although all of these bars are
higher roll on to kind of where we are
at the moment look at that red bar it
goes lower but it's actually kind of
getting further up so compared with
other oecd countries the UK is actually
climbing the rankings so you know
although we always talk about how the UK
actually in terms of union membership is
really quite low
everywhere else has been getting lower
as well and the UK hasn't been rising uh
quite so fast okay A bit of context and
a bit of history as to what we're all
experiencing at the moment whether
you're taking part in industrial action
or or feeling uh the effects of it Ed
thank you Ed Conway our data and
economics editor